- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- People don't give a fuck.
That's the most important
I thing I did learn,
that nobody cares.
Nobody cares.
Nobody is gonna care for you
like you care for yourself.
Nobody's gonna take care of you
like you can take care of yourself.
- [Interviewer] All right. Shanerrick.
- Yes.
Shanerrick where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- From Los Angeles, South
central, Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] South central.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Yes. I was raised by my
parents, well, my mother.
My father was gone for 14 years
and in prison since I was five.
- [Interviewer] What was he in prison for?
- Homicides, drug trafficking
and things like that.
You know, due to the game,
you know, the game, gaming in life.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How would you describe your childhood?
- I had an okay childhood.
It wasn't perfect.
It wasn't, you know,
that good, but it was,
you know, okay.
- [Interviewer] Any
abuse, anything like that?
- No, I wasn't really abused.
You know, I just didn't
have the best life,
you know, like some, some people.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And you got involved
in gangs at some point?
- Yes, I did when I was about 12,
I got put on at the Smithers
and I just, you know, started
living the street life.
- [Interviewer] Tell me how that started?
- Well, let me tell you a
little bit about my life.
Okay. When I was three,
when I was three my dad
kidnapped me due to,
you know, using drugs.
He was off the sherm and stuff
and he took me to the mountains,
he said he was gonna sacrifice me
and my mother came and found me.
And that kinda like,
grew anger onto my heart,
you know what I mean?
Like, why me?
You know, why would my father
do this to me, you know?
It's really touching,
you know, I don't want,
I don't want to cry or nothing but...
Damn, I hate talking about this.
- [Man] It's okay, you won't be the first.
- [Interviewer] Everybody cries here.
I cry here sometimes. (chuckles)
- It grew a lot of anger on my heart,
you know, 'cause I didn't understand,
you know, as a kid I didn't understand
why would my dad do this to me, you know?
So I never had that daddy
daughter feeling ever.
I used to just be like, you know, F him.
And it grew a lot of like, bad anger,
you know, within myself so I fought a lot.
Going to school, you
know, I fought at school,
got kicked out all my life
because, you know, I'm a small person
and people try to pick on me and stuff.
And, you know, I just was
like, I had so much anger,
it's like, I can't take that.
You know, I can't take
nobody trying to like,
hurt me no more.
So I got kicked out of school a lot.
I went to jail at 15.
I did a year and a half in
Los Paginas Juvenile Hall.
My mother couldn't take, you
know, she couldn't take it.
You know, of me, you know,
fighting in, a lot at school,
getting kicked out and all of that,
so she sent me to Los Paginas.
I got out, I ended up getting
put on at the Smithers
and I ran away from the
house multiple times,
you know, living out on the streets.
Fighting, stealing, you
know, in above or whatever.
Then I ended up getting
pregnant at 19 years old.
I lost my daughter at seven months.
(Shanerrick crying)
I fought, I went to court, I did classes
and, you know, I got my daughter back.
I had got raped by five people
with guns and everything,
you know, to my head and
I ended up finding out
I was pregnant after that.
And now I have a rape daughter.
Her name is Asia Michele Maze,
Michele (indistinct) excuse me.
And, you know, I don't
regret her or anything
but I didn't want her 'cause I didn't know
which one was the dad.
I don't know these men,
don't know nothing about
their life, nothing.
So it kind of hurts to live it every day.
You know, looking at my daughter,
knowing that she don't
have a father, you know?
Or she don't know her
other side of the family,
I'm all she got.
It already bring a lot of
pain on my heart, you know?
And it's hard to live with,
'cause I don't know how I'm gonna explain
this to her when she get older.
It's like, it's really
hard living with this.
And, you know, I lost my place at 21
because I had fought and got
my daughter back and I had her,
I had Adrian because of the simple fact,
the day I was supposed to
get an abortion with her,
my oldest brother the one
that was really close to me,
took care of me all my life,
he ended up getting shot
due to the gang banging life
and got killed on the
same day I was supposed
to get an abortion with
my daughter, you know?
And it's like, I felt like God wanted her
to be here, you know?
And he took the closest thing
to me to stop me from going
through with the abortion.
So my brother was the
sacrifice for Adrian,
that's how I look at it, you know?
And it's hurtful because
that's the only person
I ever looked up to, you know?
My brother was my everything.
He got killed on June 21st,
my appointment was June 21st
and then my daughter was born 11, 22:11.
The numbers are like so crazy
to me, you know what I mean?
Then after that, my first
baby daddy he came back,
you know, he accepted me,
you know, accepted the situation
and he accepted my daughter as his.
So he's the only father she knows.
- [Interviewer] So yo have how many kids?
- I have four now, but
then I only had two,
you know, my oldest daughter
and then the rape baby.
And my baby daddy accepted
her as his own child,
you know, because he he knew the situation
and he knew how I felt, you know?
Like, what am I going
to do with this baby?
She don't have no other family,
I don't have no help with her, no nothing.
So he stepped up to the plate
and accepted her as his child.
After that, I had another
daughter which is Renee Maze
and with my first baby daddy
because he, you know, started coming,
he came back into my
life after I got raped,
you know, and we ended
up having another baby.
And I lost her to the system
due to drugs because I started using drugs
after I had Adrian 'cause I
didn't know how to bear with,
you know, live it no more.
My brother was a gone
and I got a rape baby
and it just took a toll
on my life, you know?
So I started using crystal meth.
I lost my apartment, I lost my kids back
to domestic violence, you know,
'cause now I got into
it with my baby daddy.
We argued and fought
and then someone called
the police on us and I
lost two oldest daughters
and that's when I started
using crystal meth.
'Cause I didn't know,
I just wanted to ease my pain, you know?
And then we overcame that, I quit using.
I had Renee but I was homeless,
when I got pregnant with Renee,
I was homeless, you know?
And I was living on the
streets in the tents
and I said, well, I can't do this anymore.
You know, I gotta clean myself up,
I can't have this baby on no street.
So I went checked into a housing program,
they put me in a placement
like a transitional housing placement
and I ended up having
my daughter there and,
you know, living there for about a year
and I couldn't do they program anymore.
I couldn't do they program
anymore so I left the program.
I ended up staying in abando,
like an abandoned house.
And I started back using
crystal meth again.
And I took my daughter to the hospital
'cause she broke out in like a rash,
and they said it was from crystal meth,
you know, to her skin.
So they called the DCFS and I lost her.
And I have been on the
streets ever since by myself,
me and my baby daddy.
And we was living in tents and, you know,
right up the street from here.
On 32nd of Grand and I stayed ever since
for almost three years.
It was hard, you know?
Then I got pregnant again
and I had my fourth daughter
and I started doing, you know,
I left the crystal meth alone
once I got pregnant again.
Well I smoked through my pregnancy really,
you know, until I was like
six and a half months.
And then I said, you know, I said,
well, my baby should mean more to me,
you know, than these drugs, you know?
So I have to stop using.
So I stopped using for about three months,
you know, due to so my
system can be cleaned out,
the baby can come out with
no drugs in her system.
And I ended up having Deanna
and right now I'm still
homeless at this moment.
I'm still living on the
streets at this moment.
It's hard because all
I want to do is really
be a good mom that, you
know, I know I can be.
It is sad, I'm not a bad person, you know?
It's just life is rough for me
for the things I went through, I don't,
you know, I don't accept
that I deserve this life,
you know, I didn't ask for this.
I didn't ask to be raped,
I didn't ask to, you know,
have to live on the streets.
I tried to go to school,
I tried to go to college,
I tried to better myself
and it seems like nothing
ever works for me.
- [Interviewer] How are you supporting,
how are you supporting yourself now?
- I sell drugs,
I do braid hair,
I have a lot of talent, you know?
I braid hair for a living
and I sell crystal meth
and I sell, you know,
crack, drugs or whatever
to make, you know, my little ends meet.
Or just to feed myself every day
and, you know, to try to like
give me a motel or whatever.
To try to give me a room to
take a shower or whatever.
Like right now I just lost
everything I have right now.
And the police pulled me over,
they took all my drugs,
they gave me a ticket
and they let me go, which
was a blessing, you know?
But that was my money to
make, to get me a room
'cause I haven't took a shower
in three days already, you know?
I'm just like overwhelmed with my life.
I'm overwhelmed.
I can't take it no more.
I don't know what else to do,
I seek for help, you know what I'm saying?
I'm searching, you know, I
just want to better myself
that's it, you know?
I don't know what else
like, this is my life.
- [Interviewer] what emotion
do you deal with the most,
is it depression or anger or?
- Depression and anger,
you know?
- [Interviewer] Anxiety?
- Yeah, it's really depressing
that my kids don't have a
mother that I want to be,
you know what I mean?
It's hurtful my kids is getting lonely
they try to live with people
and they want to be with me,
they can't, you know what I mean?
I can't see them everyday like I want to.
It hurts that I don't wake
up with my kids every day,
you know what I mean?
That's a lot of depression within itself.
Having to live on the
streets, is very hard.
It's raining out here, it's cold,
it is really cold, you know what I mean?
Who wants to be on the streets?
No one.
I don't think so.
I don't want to be on those streets.
All I want is to get me a place,
all I want is to have my kids, you know?
I want them to be able to
wake up with me every day.
- [Interviewer] Are they
with another family now or?
- They're with my family members,
my granny have two of them and
my mother have two of them.
- [Interviewer] So there's a
chance that you could get back
into their lives?
- There's a chance.
Yeah. I have the
opportunity to get them back
but I have to get stable and it's hard
for me to get stable because I don't have
the income that they expect
you to have to afford a place,
you know what I mean?
I do receive social security,
but it's not enough, it's
not enough, you know?
they want you to make two, three times
over the amount for the
rent and I don't get that.
I don't have that.
So my applications get denied, you know?
And I have no other choices, you know?
So the programs, the
housing programs they,
they like, they want you to do
this and that and the other.
Come in on curfew times
and all this and it's like,
really hard to do.
It's really hard to do, you know?
'Cause the little money I
get, I have to pay for gas,
I do have a car.
My grandmother helped me get that,
you know, so I wouldn't
have to walk, you know,
I can help her come
through and take my kids,
you know, those things or whatever.
You know, she got tired of
seeing me walking around
so she gave me the money
to help me get a car
so I can be able to get around,
you know, from my mom house to her house,
you know, or to my destinations, you know?
She's like, I know it's
hard out here for you.
That's was like the only
person I really got, you know,
even though my mother is here,
my mother do have some of my kids.
That's a blessing within itself
but it's like my mother, she never worked.
You know, she receives
social security herself.
She gets section eight
and she don't have it,
you know, she's not the mother
that haves it like that.
So she cannot help me, you know, as much.
So it has been a rough
life for me, you know?
I have to get everything like on my own.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'm 30 now.
I just turned 30, July 15th.
I'm too old to be living
like this, you know?
That's how I feel, I should
be in a better place,
a better spot within life.
I'm scared to talk to
anybody, due to getting raped,
I'm scared to find me another guy friend.
Right now me and my baby daddy
is not together right now at the moment.
I do have custody of my
youngest child right now
but the reason why my
mother have her is because
it's cold out here in these streets.
Usually I have her in the motels
and stuff with me or whatever
but as her mother, I
don't want her out here,
I want better for her.
You know, I don't want to be
tagging no baby along with me,
with this lifestyle that
I'm living, it's not right,
she don't deserve that.
If you are at home with my other daughter,
'cause she had custody of my third child
but if you at home with her, you know,
let her sister be with her, you know?
It only makes sense.
This baby don't want, she don't, you know,
she need a good meal,
cooked meal and stuff like,
she needs to sleep in
a warm bed every night.
I don't want to be putting her,
bouncing her from room to room,
you know, it's okay for me, I'll be okay
but my baby is not fine
out here in these streets.
That really hurt, you know?
My car is a mess right now.
It's filthy in the car
'cause I have so much stuff
because I have my stuff plus
there's baby's stuff, you know?
Sometimes we have to sleep in the car
'cause I don't have, you know,
I don't make the money to get a room,
you know, and it's pitiful , it's sad.
- [Interviewer] Do you see
the world as a cruel place
or do you see that you're,
you grew up into a family
and an environment that was very tough,
very different than most people's?
- Sometime I do see the world
as a little cruel, you know,
from the cruel people
that's in it, you know?
'Cause they kind of like
really fucked me up,
you know, within my head,
excuse my language but...
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but it just seems
like the cards were stacked against you
because you didn't have the parenting
that most people,
- Yes, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Take
for granted and perhaps
the opportunities and stability
and all the things that many
people take for granted.
You didn't have that.
- Yeah.
And I would love that, you
know, I would love that.
I would love that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
you seem intelligent, you
seem willing and capable.
- I'm very intelligent, I'm very smart,
you know, I have a lots
of common sense, you know?
I know I can do better, I know I can.
But life is so hard and
tough right now on me,
you know, and things
have happened to me that,
you know, really like
messed up my mind, you know?
So I cannot focus like how
I want to focus, you know?
Cause I'm scared.
I'm scared.
I'm scared to do anything like...
- [Interviewer] What
are you most scared of?
- People, so I don't like them.
'Cause I don't know what
they can do to me, you know?
They tried to take my life.
I pleaded for my life when they raped me.
I pleaded for my life and they spared me.
It has been really, you
know, hard to deal with,
and I've been living with
this for nine years now.
And nowadays life is like,
I don't know which way to go, you know?
I don't know what to do.
I don't want a, I don't
want no guy friend.
I can't even get a guy friend
because I'm scared to talk to them,
you know what I'm saying?
Because it's like, what's
your motive, you know?
Why do you want to talk to me?
Why do you want to, why do
you want me to be your friend,
why do you want my number?
I have to ask a thousand
questions and above
and I don't want to do all of that,
I shouldn't have to, I
shouldn't have to be scared.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like really hard to cope with people
so I stay to myself.
I stay by myself.
Jasmine is the first friend
I have had in a long time,
a long time.
I don't deal with no
people on this streets,
not even my own homies
that's from my hood.
I, you know, I stay in my
area, you know, in the hood
is because, you know,
this is where I'm from,
I got put on this hood, you know?
But far as hanging, chilling,
you know, kicking it,
I don't do that with them.
- [Interviewer] But if you
go to another neighborhood,
do you get...
- [Shanerrick] I don't go
to no other neighborhoods.
- [Interviewer] What happens if you do?
- I mean, I get respect
because of the toughness that's in me,
you know what I'm saying?
I have, you know, been in
different areas or whatever
but I go there to sell my drugs.
- [Interviewer] What could happen
if you went out of your gang's area?
- I can get killed,
you know, I can get shot at,
I can get us in fights quickly
because this side can be Crips, this side
you know, I'm a Blood so,
you know, if I go in the wrong areas,
these are Crips, you
know, they can jump on me
and they might feel like, you know,
bitch why are you over
here, you know what I mean?
Like, you're in the
wrong area, you feel me?
Banging what you banging.
So it's like, a real tough situation
to like really live with,
you know what I'm saying?
You gotta be a little
tough, you know what I mean?
You gotta have a little
heart, can't be scared.
But I'm really truly scared
within myself though, you know?
Because now I have to be this person
that I don't want to be so
people won't fuck with me,
you know what I mean?
I have to carry knives
and fucking mace and,
you know, shit weapons or whatever
because I am a small, petite person
and if these, you know,
if I go in their area
and they feel like they want to jump on me
because of the sect that I claim,
I'm gonna have to protect
myself, you know what I mean?
So, yes, I'm gonna have
to pull out a knife
and shank a motherfucker.
Now I got to take your life.
And all of this is like,
it built up a lot of like, man, I don't,
I don't really don't
know how to explain it,
you know what I mean?
The life that I live,
but this is how it is.
I'm not no killer, but don't push me,
you know what I mean?
If I have to do this, then
this is what I gotta do.
'Cause I gotta eat too,
I gotta feed myself,
you know what I mean?
I'm not trying to come
step on nobody's toes,
I ain't trying to come
disrespect. y'all sect,
you know what I mean?
But if I'm over here in this area
and I see as there's money
getting made over here,
I'm gonna come trying to make me some
'cause I'm only trying
to make my ends meet
so I could be okay.
'Cause I don't have nobody else out here,
I don't have no help, I
don't have nothing out here.
- [Interviewer] You feel
like you're on your own?
- I'm out here on my own, you know?
The only thing I have is my mother
and my granny taking care of my kids
and that's the only
thing I'm grateful for.
Other than that, I have nothing.
I'm just out here by
myself, no place to live,
you know what I'm saying?
Sleeping on the streets,
sometimes I have money for
food, sometimes I don't.
My friend helps me sometimes, you know?
Just to get a meal.
Jasmine, you see me
every day and you know,
she knows what I go through.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- People don't give a fuck.
That's the most important
thing I did learn.
That nobody cares.
Nobody cares.
Nobody is gonna care for you
like you care for yourself.
Nobody is gonna take care of you
like you can take care of yourself.
So if I don't start, you
know, trying to change,
no one's gonna change
anything for me, you know?
So I have to seek out for help for myself,
you know what I mean?
I have to reach out to people
so I can do better for myself.
It's all about yourself
'cause no one else cares.
You know, even family
members, they don't care
'cause they feel like
they have their own life
and their own situations and
they own bills and problems.
So they don't wanna help the next
not knowing that
their family member or their
cousin or brother or sister
is out here really losing
it, you know what I'm saying?
Going down the drain,
you know what I'm saying?
Just a little bit of your help,
it can probably build me up a whole lot.
You know, it'll give me a
little bit more strength
if you just cared a little bit.
But by you not having a
support system or support team,
you bound to drown.
I appreciate my only friend right here.
She gave me the little bit
of strength to keep me going.
You know, I cry every day in my car.
I sit in the car every
day, I stay in my car
and I cry because all I want
to do is have a better life,
you know, better things.
I want to do better.
I want to do better for me and my kids
'cause they don't deserve this, you know?
I just want to be here for them, you know?
I want to show them that I do care,
I care for them and I'll always care
'cause I see that nobody cares for me.
I don't want to give up on myself
'cause that's where I'm headed to.
I'm ready to give up because I don't know,
I don't know what turns to make.
It's hard.
It's hard. It's hard for...
I don't, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] I'm gonna make
your day a little bit easier.
- I appreciate it.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.